you went from getting pregnant at 13
marine and getting divorced being a
waitress in a strip club
like all the things that probably aren't
super cool
being the daughter of you know a pastor
your life is not random you are not here
by accident
when you arrive on whatever scene it is
heaven touches earth your goodness
your life your creativity is heaven
touching earth what do you think
is one of the most important habits
that would lead to a big shift asking
yourself how are you
nothing can be healed until we admit
that we're broken
amen i mean i'm a guy but i still got
the chills
you have to go back and use that when i
need it that's fantastic
wow
and there she is hi how are you doing
i'm doing great how are you i'm
fantastic
ladies and gentlemen believe nation i
want to introduce you to the one and
only
sarah jakes roberts she is an
entrepreneur
she's a pastor she is the author of a
new book
i got it right here woman evolved this
is launch day for her i'm so excited
welcome aboard thank you i'm so excited
to be here i'm excited today is like
already through the roof so i know this
is just going to take you to another
level
yeah like talk me through that how
excited are you i know
things are just crazy on launch day but
what's it been like for you so far today
so far it's been great i got up at 3 30
to do some press
in new york so i'm like running off of
pure adrenaline it feels like 3 p.m
right now
um but it's been great so many people
are actually getting the book
and so we've been talking about it for a
long time so for people to have
it in their hands and to be ingesting
the information it's beautiful
i love if if you have not picked it up
women evolved for the youtube audience
we'll link it up in the description
below
go go get it go get your copy uh what i
love about
your journey and what you've poured into
the book is
you have been the woman evolved right
you went from
being you know the daughter of bishop
t.d jakes and all these expectations i
guess
of of what you know daughter of a pastor
would do but
getting pregnant at 13 marine and
getting divorced
being a waitress in a strip club like
all the things that
probably aren't super cool being the
daughter of you know a pastor but but
then to go from
that to this to to being the pastor to
having
you know your books it's been your own
evolution which has been amazing to
watch
how do you let go and i think it's where
people struggle how do you let go of
that old story how do you let go of
i am no law i don't want to be this
person anymore
because i need to evolve into something
else you know what evan that's exactly
what people say to themselves is i don't
want to be this person anymore that's
what i said to myself
at 13 that's what i said at 14 when i
had my son and said i don't want to be
this person anymore and the truth is
nothing changed for my life until i
embrace that person because that's a
part of who i
am and until i take the time to embrace
that person to figure out where their
insecurities are
to figure out where their weaknesses are
then i'm running from my
own weaknesses and basically i'm going
to run into a situation that i'm not
prepared to handle because i haven't
dissected my past
and so it wasn't until i stopped running
from that person and instead decided to
embrace her whoever she was however
messed up she was
however much therapy she needed did i
really begin to see my life change
and so for somebody who is watching this
or is you know picking up the book and
is kind of tired of their life the way
it is
and tired of being told what to do and
put inside a box
what are the first steps to
break into the fear to create a life
that you want what would you tell her
i think it starts with perspective on
who you are
a lot of times because we are so
inundated with other people's
experiences we can begin to believe that
our lives are
random that it doesn't really matter and
i believe that
every life was created with intention
our job is to show
up with that reality to our identity in
everything that we do
and so i think it starts with realizing
your life is not random you are not here
by accident
when you arrive on whatever scene it is
heaven touches
earth your goodness your light your
creativity
is heaven touching earth if we can
embrace that mentality
when we walk into a relationship when we
walk into a business opportunity
then our goal is to be a gift to
whatever we are doing and to not need
our brokenness
our insecurities our instability makes
us
need something i need someone to
validate me i need someone to say that
i'm okay
we have to flip the script on that by
first saying i am here to be a giver
i am here to flow in my unique offerings
my unique gift my
unique anointing and that perspective
changes the way we show up in the world
the
book really outlines how we do that
right how we unwind our mind so that we
can show up in that space but it's
really important that we do it
she's preaching
can't help it i love it um so
i mean the main theme of the book
without getting into all the details
because you guys got to go pick up a
copy
is around the sort of eve and you know
the great line you said was eve
knew better but she didn't do better she
didn't do better
she knew better but she didn't do better
and i think it's something a lot of
people can relate to
we know we should be doing this thing
over here and yet
we keep running into these old patterns
and and letting ourselves down when
people round us down
how how do we break out and
when we know better to actually how do
we get the courage to actually go and do
better
okay so what happened to eve she
explains it in this story we just are so
like and i have to tell you i was one of
those people
that said okay i don't know how many
people are out there who actually say
this but i
was a person who said when i get to
heaven i am going to have an argument
with eve like we are going to have to
talk about how she messed it up
for all of humanity like i'm out here
struggling to you can do your one job
but
i decided that i couldn't be an
empowerer of women and want to fight eve
when i got to heaven so i had to do some
work got to do some inner work
to fix my soul and when i started
studying her life and studying what took
place in that story
i saw that she said that the serpent
deceived me and then i ate that word
deceived is like a slow
seduction of the mind and part of the
reason why we're not able to break toxic
patterns while we know better but don't
do better
is that there is a fracture in our mind
a fracture in our thinking
which makes us think that we know better
but we don't actually know better we
just
think we should it's like when you think
you should start a diet you eat french
fries and work out
but when you know you should do better
it changes the way you show up my goal
in woman evolve is to help you identify
that fracture
that changed the way that you eat that
change the way that you show up in the
world
and if we can find that fracture then we
can heal it we can create boundaries so
that you don't have to continue that
pattern
but most importantly you can begin to
revolutionize your life
people ask me what the name of the book
is it's called the woman there it is
woman evolve yes and again for the
youtube audience we'll link it up in the
description below you can one click go
go pick it up
um you had this great line that you said
i wrote it down i wrote it down here
because it was so like
man it gave me chill so i want to read
and get your deeper perspective so you
said
when we become comfortable in a lesser
version
of who we are it's because we're afraid
that we can't meet the expectations of
who we think we could become
i'm getting i'm getting chills again
just reading that back take us deeper
and explain you know for the audience
what what you mean by that
you know it's not that we don't
necessarily want to do better or that we
don't want more out of life
more is just exhausting our present is
so
taxing on us that we feel like to even
stretch
more to want more to heal from this
heartbreak to want to start a new life
like this life where i am right now has
cost me so much
that i don't even believe that i can
stretch beyond it and when we don't
believe that we can meet the expectation
and that we stay in the comfort of
restriction
and yet the reality is that that next
that next level vision that god has for
your life that healing
is going to allow for you to have
creativity and energy and breakthrough
that you could have never had if you
stayed in this level
and i think it's important for people to
know that you don't have to take your
same energy and your same creativity to
the new level
that new level has new creativity it has
new insight new innovation new strategy
all of the new that require that is
required to build that manifestation is
connected to the next we just have to be
brave enough
to move in that direction
how important is community in all of
this because i see i mean you're on
instagram and you're sharing your
community
and giving so much love to the people
who who have
picked up a copy of the book like how
important is it to have a community to
help you on this journey
oh my goodness you've got to be around
like-minded people woman evolve is a
book now but it really is
a community right so woman evolved
started with this revelation i had about
eve if you say
evolve slowly you pick up eve's name and
i wanted to connect with other women who
felt like that like i know better i
don't always do better but i believe
better how do i connect the dots
and community is the place where we get
to say this is where i was wounded
this is how i healed it's a place where
someone who is fresh can come in and we
can help to move them forward as well
and woman evolve is very much so like i
tell the people who
follow woman evolved like i'm honored to
be a part of this community i'm so glad
to be a part of this sisterhood
because they make me better they make me
stretch they make me step into this
moment they make me own everything
that's happening in my life
and i know that i'm better because of
the delegation that's what i call the
woman evolve community the delegation
i love it and it really seems like it's
not
even so much about you it's about the
movement
there's another word that you're trying
to create to help
women step out and step up in their
lives
if it's about me i messed up you know
what i mean like i don't want to build
something that points people back to me
i want to hold a mirror
that helps people to see themselves the
way that god sees them
and so i have no desire for it to be
just about me
of course like i'm the vessel that god
uses to like create the vision and to
write the books
but at the end of the day i feel like i
have a responsibility to make sure that
i don't take in the light
but that i shine the light into dark
spaces and on the people who need it the
most
community is it's necessary it's not
about me
i love that uh so what would you tell
people who
they read it and they love it and i feel
like it's time for me to step up and
change and i don't want to be this
person anymore and then they tell their
friends or their
their maybe their husband or some of
their best friends from high school and
they're like you you can't
what come on you can't do that who do
you think you are to go and do that
thing
and then and then she kind of talks
yourself down from doing the thing
what would you recommend for that person
i would tell that woman that she's got
to believe it for herself first
a lot of times we make an announcement
about our transformation because we want
other people to validate it
i want you to co-sign on my evolution
your evolution does not need a cosign it
has been
endorsed and stamped from heaven so all
you have to do is walk this thing out
and then walking it out
be patient with yourself you've been in
a toxic pattern or an insecure pattern
for a long time this is working a new
muscle we're working your faith muscle
we're working your confidence muscle so
let's practice this thing let's change
one thing at a time
and then when we've mastered that thing
let's move to the next thing
and i feel like that's exactly what we
have to know the revolution is closer
than we think
but we've got to practice we've got to
have a war strategy and we've got to be
patient with the process
i love it somebody clipped that that's a
that's fire that's great
talk about the even the in the titling
and the thinking it's
evolution not revolution which means
that it's not like
we're not going all in crazy mode but
hey this is a slow shift of our habits
behaviors that
patience is kind of required to make an
evolution happen
why evolution set a revolution you know
um i believe that the evolution birth of
the revolution right
so um i thought about calling it
revolution but i do think that
revolution already within con
in its connotation makes you think it
happens very rapidly
and yet when i look back over my life i
see that it was really
small things along the way that led to
my revolution
and i take comfort in that when i think
that i have to like whenever evan after
i finish this book stuff like i'm gonna
have to do something about the french
fries i've been eating to cope with
distressed at this season
and like most of the time i decide like
i'm gonna go from cheeseburgers to vegan
the very next day and then i fail and
end up back on cheeseburgers because i
tried to revolutionize without having
the process of evolving where i
am and so i think it's important that we
are willing to take the time and be
patient with ourselves and then we look
up one day it's like a suddenly kind of
thing
suddenly i look up and i'm not that girl
anymore suddenly i have confidence it
felt suddenly but i was doing the work
along the way
and all the work i did i put in the book
because i wanted women to step into a
suddenly moment
i love it what do you think is one of
the most important
habits that is simple to do that that
women can do every day
that would lead to a big shift even
though it doesn't feel like it's that
big a habit
daily asking yourself how are you
asking yourself how are you and
responding with truth
uh i write this in the book but
sometimes we are so busy
creating a picture of our life that we
don't make space for where we fit in the
picture
remember when we used to go to those old
portrait studios and the photographer
would have you over there and fix your
bow tie and fix a little plaid that you
had on
and then he gets behind the camera to
take the picture that's how we live our
lives we're
creating this life that we want to get
behind the camera of and take a picture
of and yet how
are you brings you into this picture
because if i know how i'm doing i can
make decisions based on that
i mean to be able to say i'm hurting i'm
broken i feel
fragile today i don't feel as strong as
i should and i think to be aware of
where you
are from day to day helps you build a
life that is a reflection of your truth
and not just the picture you're trying
to take so that other people can marvel
at how well you're doing
so if if somebody asks themselves right
now the woman watching this says
hey how am i i'm actually taking a
usually we give a bs answer to somebody
else right yeah yeah things are good
right
of course or instagram where it's like
things are great look at my beautiful
life meanwhile you know you're crying in
your room
so if if you know a woman watching this
says
i'm broken that's her answer
what does she do next yeah the first of
all
i would say to come to that place of
realization is
powerful because nothing can be healed
until we admit that we're broken
and then i think we have to ask
ourselves she would have to ask herself
what would it take
for me to be healed what does that
healed version of myself look like
and what do i need to do in order to get
there what do i need to cut off that has
become poison
that infects me further and i'm already
open and wounded
what therapy do i need what services do
i need to get plugged into what prayers
what meditation what books do i need to
be reading
to really begin to create a strategy for
healing a doctor doesn't just say oh
you're broken and sends you home
it gives you a prescription to help you
get there and i believe
as a person in faith as a believer that
there is a prescription for your healing
i don't care how broken you are i don't
care how many years you've been broken
how many years you've been down and now
there is a prescription for your healing
our mission on earth my
purpose is to make sure that every woman
who was connected to the prescription i
have
received it and there are other people
who believe that and you got to get
plugged into those people
if we were to give women that
prescription
and and do a prayer and imagine a woman
who
has just told herself that she's broken
and she needs a prayer
and she's going to fast forward to this
this point
on this youtube video as a reminder that
whenever
she feels broken that she's not alone
and that
there is hope and that she can't get
through it can we do a quick prayer for
her
i would love that i would love that god
i thank you for the woman who stumbled
across this video
her heart is tender it's fragile
and yet in this moment you're offering
her hope
may she come into awareness of the
knowledge
that you see her heal that you see her
whole you see her powerful
father my prayer is that your presence
that carries peace that carries
wholeness would meet her
right now and that she would fall so in
love with that presence that she creates
space in her world to experience it all
the time
father i know that you're going to take
everything that has ever happened in her
just like you did for me
and you're going to show her that you
can use it all to create a masterpiece
and so may she surrender to this truth
but may she not stay there
may she be resurrected anew no longer
wounded no longer hurting but rather a
beacon of glory
for other women to be inspired by amen
amen i mean i'm a guy but i still got
the chills you have to go back and use
that when i need it
that's fantastic wow um
that's great so i mean thank you for
that i think that could be powerful and
listen
if you're struggling go back and listen
to that part again or clip it and make
that your ringtone i mean if you need
that
it exists you don't have to suffer alone
um the book again woman
evolve we'll link it up down the
description below this is launch day for
sarah we're so excited
uh you said that you're shy and i think
people would find that to be
very strange not believable
like who is this woman she says she's
shy uh
how do you how do you be shy i think
because i think this is part of the
evolution too like how can you be shy
and do what you do because a lot of
women who tell themselves that i'm too
shy or i'm too introverted i could never
do that so how did you get over that to
do what you do
you know i found the thing that was
worth me
shedding what kept me bound in order to
step into it i wish i could say that
better that's something i say when i'm
preaching but i found the thing that was
bigger than me
that was bigger than how i felt that was
bigger than me being shy
and introverted and the space between my
shyness and my confidence
is the belief in what i have to say and
the belief in restoration the belief in
redemption that i have because of my own
journey and my own walk
allows me to stretch outside of how i
feel
about something that's a lot of times
our feelings keep us stuck
and our feelings are worthy of
acknowledging but we have to determine
am i going to allow my feelings to drive
my destiny
and so if i allow that to happen i
wouldn't be having this conversation i
wouldn't be able to share my story with
so many people and so when i found the
thing that was bigger than me i allowed
it to be bigger than me
i mean in doing that is because you
connected to service
that this is going to help other people
without a doubt
i don't the only time i go on live the
only time i post
the only time i do anything is when i
feel like i have something to say that
will help other people i don't talk for
the sake of talking that's not my
personality
that's not what i do you know but um
when i
when i do connect i like to make it
meaningful
and how do you advise women
to tap into what their higher level of
service would be of how their message
might help other people
you know how do we find it i think that
purpose has become such a nebulous term
right and no one knows what it is or how
we find it is it gonna come smack me in
the face
do i need to go do something to go
discover it for me and what i write
about in the book is that purpose is
living with the
consciousness one that my life is not
random but that everywhere i go i have
an
opportunity to add value and if we see
our life
as a tool that adds value no matter
where i am whether my name is in life
or i'm working at the non-profit on the
corner my life is a tool
that purpose and that sense of service
shows up in everything that we do
so i would tell women to not be so
caught up with this idea of what is my
big thing but instead what is my small
thing how do i
bring purpose to this job bring purpose
to raising this child
and our life has a sense of identity of
fulfillment and value when we're able to
show up in that way
and you could always help somebody today
in even a small boy
yeah yeah absolutely what are what are
some for somebody who might feel like
purpose is too big
and i can't bring value what are some
easy ways to
just give love to somebody what would
you say oh my goodness be kind in these
social media streets people are out here
cutting up we need more kindness on
social media
we need more kindness to our cashiers i
mean i set up a little station for my
amazon drivers because they come to my
house at this point where they might as
well move in
um but i put on a little snack station
with drinks and fruit
and whenever like postmates come by they
say thank you for thinking of us there
are small ways that we can make a big
difference in the lives of people
there are organizations that need help
supporting the causes that they're um
undergirding in the community look for
ways to have service and you'll find
them there's
always always something that needs to be
done
and saying thank you or giving love is
free
absolutely absolutely yeah
i love it um you talked about poison
before
what do you think are the biggest
poisons that people have in their lives
that prevent them from building that
life they want
comparison because we're building by
what we see our neighbors house look
like and so when we see our foundation
is off we take our whole foundation and
throw it away
when our master bedroom is not big
enough we throw the whole master bedroom
away
and we're building our lives based off
of what we see in someone else's life
and judging our work based off of what
we see
in social media obviously magnifies that
in many ways and so i think comparison
is one of the
most dangerous poisons that we drink
from each day and i think that now this
is the hard work that people don't like
to do
but when we recognize that i've seen
something that makes me feel
uh badly about myself or poorly about
where i am
we have to identify that lie we have to
identify that thought and then we have
to speak
truth over that that's that renewing of
the mind
and in the process of doing that we're
able to actually celebrate people
instead of seeing it as it being
um a reflection of where we are not
what would you tell somebody who might
right now be comparing themselves to you
oh goodness girl if you're going to
compare yourself to me you got to
compare yourself to the full story we
got to start at 13.
when you was rubbing your belly we got
to start with the church mothers telling
you to get up and apologize
we got to compare the whole story and
even when you do that you have to
recognize that as long as you're
comparing yourself to my story
that no one is maximizing your life i
want to see your testimony i want to see
how you come out on the other side you
didn't have a team pregnancy but you had
something
that bruised your heel and i want to see
how you take that same heel and use it
to crush something that's happening in
your world
i love it one last question talk about
it here it says right on the cover so
guys again
woman evolve we'll link it up in the
description below right under here it
says
break up with your fears
what do you recommend for people to
break up with their biggest fear oh
goodness
everyone has um a different fear
but i think the best way to break up
with your fears is like
to make fear your audience to um
decide that i'm not going to allow fear
to control me anymore
and fear keeps so many of us bound and
the best way to do that is to rebel
that's why that revolution where it
becomes powerful is because i'm going to
rebel against my fears
start writing down what your fears tell
you what do your fears tell you about
who you aren't or who you are
let's write them down and let's start
rebelling against them i'm shy my fear
tells me i'm shy
i can't speak publicly i fumble over my
words
their words don't always flow well and
yet here i am on instagram live fumbling
and mumbling and hitting some gold every
now and then because i have decided i
will not be bound by my fears
well there definitely is a lot of gold
in this interview and not not that many
fumbles and bumblings
but anyway ladies and gentlemen the book
is called women evolve again we'll link
that up in the description go pick up
your copy
sarah thank you so much for joining us
uh congrats on the launch day i'm super
excited to see this thing
uh take over because you're you're
infecting the world with positivity
and appreciate your time today thank you
thank you for this time
much love everybody take care
if you want to see the one on one i did
with sarah's father bishop td
jigs check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
i'm pretty animated things are out here
pretty loudly that's true